- On this episode, I answer
a shitload of questions.
(rap music)
You ask questions, and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
What's up everybody?
This is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 71
of the #AskGaryVee show.
We decided since 71 is
such a special number,
and you know, such a significant number,
that we're gonna have a very special show.
It's gonna be called the
rapid fire #AskGaryVee show.
India, are you ready?
This is gonna be pretty intense.
DRock, ready?
Let's get into
the show.
- [Voiceover] Tim asked, "If
you're not from an English
speaking country should
you produce content
in English anyways, or should you produce
content in your mother language?"
- Tim, that's a great question
with a very simple answer, which is great,
because I'm answering a
boatload questions today.
The answer is you should be
speaking in the language of
the people you're trying to reach.
If you're trying to reach
the consumers in your native
tongue, speak in your native tongue,
unless English is also the second language
that is covering let's say 80, 90% of the
speakers, because you
get the serendipity if it
goes outside the boundaries, but it always
is reverse engineering the
language of your client.
If you're trying to reach
English speaking consumers,
then you gotta speak in English,
and again, if English is
enough of a second language
with a big enough broad stroke according
to the overall market,
that would be the reason
the rationale around English
otherwise it's a native tongue game.
- [Voiceover] Tom Rowley
asked, "Trader Joe's
has a cult like following with
no social media presences.
What are your thoughts?"
- Tom, I think Trader
Joe's is leaving action
on the table.
I don't know what else to say.
Clearly their business is great,
and I keep saying it marketing,
great marketing doesn't solve
a business's problem, but it can
accelerate a business's enormous
awesomemess.
I don't know.
That doesn't sound right,
but the bottom line
is very simply, Trader Joe's
you may be thinking that you're
doing it cool or that brands shouldn't
engage if they're awesome,
and you're a great brand,
but I fundamentally believe
they're leaving a lot
of action on the table.
I love when people are like, yo Gary,
I don't need social
media or good marketing.
My business is up 23%.
I'm like what's wrong with 60%?
Why can't your business be up 90% Joe?
- [Voiceover] Luke asks, "My
litte sister has Instagram
and Snapchat, but has
no interest in Facebook.
What do you think the
future holds for Facebook?"
- Luke, I think Facebook has an issue
about the growing population.
I don't see your little sister
and her little friends jumping
from Snapchat and Insta
into Facebook as they get older.
No, Insta and Snapchat will
become more like Facebook,
but will Facebook be
in a place where it'll
be able to keep it's 35 to 70 year olds
on it's platform and not have them go down
to Insta and Snapchat.
Listen, Zucks is an assassin.
There's a reason he bought Instagram.
There's a reason he tried
to pay three billion.
Let me just remind the market Stunwin.
Steve's not here often these days.
Let's just show him.
- Hey everybody.
- [Gary] He's like all super
VIP and never around anymore.
He tried to buy Snapchat
for three billion.
I think what the future
holds for Facebook is
if they keep crushing it and
doing the things they're doing
which I think they're doing well,
and they hold onto their
30, 32, 35 and above
crowd, it'll be an enormous business,
but over time that will corrode over
15, 20, 30 years, but don't forget
Insta is the new Facebook right now.
They've got a long lineage.
They'll have to make sure
that they get the next
one after Snapchat, and
that's probably their
biggest vulnerabilities
for a decade out game,
but don't forget they bought Oculus,
and so they're doing a lot of stuff.
Look at them like Google.
Facebook is the infrastructure
for over the top television
or for free internet in America,
or has the number one
phone in seven years.
That wouldn't surprise
me, because that's where
I think Zuck's leadership is taking them.
- [Voiceover] Melissa asks, "Hey Gary,
Morale in public education is low.
How can I as a teacher help to create a
Thank You Economy Culture
despite government mandates,
ineffective curriculum, low funding,
and most of all, high stress
and pressure on teachers?"
- Melissa, you can't.
The machine is too big, it's too broken,
and what you can do as an individual
I think is do what I do
with the #AskGaryVee show
which is I think I'm doing education here.
You can put out great
content to the universe
using the platforms that can reach people,
and so trying to change
an entire machine is extremely difficult.
I, with all my charisma and energy
and clout, can't move big corporate 500
organizations.
You wanna move the entire
US academic infrastructure.
It's not gonna happen.
I'm sorry that I'm being realistic here.
What you can do though
is there's something an
individual can always do.
They can play in the places that are the
white space.
The white space right
now is for you to put out
curriculum on your own, to the world
in a format like this, or whatever.
You wanna make slideshares, great.
You wanna do Khan Academy stuff, great.
You wanna do slideshare, great.
You need to work around
the system, not within it.
- [Voiceover] Paul asks,
"So Sprint is taking over
the Radio Shack stores,
but what is the relevance
of Sprint?
Is Sprint the new Radio Shack?"
- Paul, that's a great question.
I don't know what Sprint's got in mind
for Radio Shack.
I think physical retail
stores need to be innovative
and have experiences wrapped around them.
You're right.
I think there's a very interesting
point here that if Sprint
just puts up Sprint stores and
executes in a Radio Shack way
they become the new Radio Shack.
If they don't and they
take a page out of let's
say Barnes and Nobles,
that realized they couldn't
compete with Amazon if it was just books,
and made it more of a coffee
shop, place you visited,
a community hub, and
they trickled out some
sales from that.
It all depends on the execution.
You are what you are.
People are always like, hey,
our brand represents this.
This is what we have to do.
It's not true. What you do
then becomes your brand,
and so the execution
of Sprint over the next
24 months will dictate if they're
the new Radio Shack or they're the new
Sprint retail store 3.0.
- [Voiceover] Charles asks,
"How do you hustle faster?"
- Charles, stop focusing on dumb shit
and just keep moving and
don't be scared of breaking
anything, and don't
think about perfection,
and there is no perfect way to cross
your Ts and dot your Is,
and don't be crippled,
and don't be romantic,
and just move, and have
no seconds to breathe,
and just schedule on schedule on schedule.
Five minute meetings, 10 minute meetings,
three minute meetings,
eight minute meetings,
and just move.
- [Voiceover] Rui asks, "Last
year you nailed it when you
recommended us to use Medium.
What are your recommendations for 2015?"
- I got nothing yet.
(laughter)
Actually I do have something.
Sorry India.
- [India] That's fine.
- Scared the crap out of you,
and I have a feeling DRock
is gonna use this footage.
LinkedIn is catching my attention.
I'm very shocked over what I'm seeing
over the last 10 days of just natively
posting content in my Linked In feed.
Now I have a huge audience there,
and so I don't know how that
works out for other people,
but LinkedIn is freaking
me out a little bit.
I'm not talking about
Pulse or Influencer.
I'm just talking about
my feed, my account.
- Gary, how would you market
a business in an industry
that has a bad reputation
and people only use it
in emergencies?
Let's say, for example
the towing industry?
Thanks Gary.
- Matt, this is a great question,
and I've talked about this before.
If you're in the towing
industry, what I would
actually be in is
I would become a media company
in the travel and car industry.
I would create a site, you know,
especially if you're regional.
I'm gonna assume that you're
doing this towing in a regional
area, let's call it Kansas City.
I would literally call
Kansas City highway.com
where you're reviewing the restaurants,
you're giving people shortcuts.
You become a community hub of content
and information, and
then sprinkled throughout
every third or fourth post you talk
about your service.
Maybe you do a real hardcore right hook
where they click or use the QR code,
they put you and your company's name
into their phone, and
then you can control that
and put emergency roadside assistance.
I like that.
That was a really good idea.
That's what you should do.
You should become the content player
around the culture of driving,
highway culture, travel,
and the general area.
- [Voiceover] Damon asks,
"Girl Scouts cookies are going
on sale tomorrow, if
you were a Girl Scout,
how would you maximize your sales?"
- Damon, one of the moves I would use is
try to go viral and go very practical.
Clouds and dirts,
so I would do hardcore
one-on-one activation.
Literally, I would have
a five minute meeting
with my parents and ask them who their
11 best friends are, and then call them
and ask them to buy the damn cookies.
I would also then go outside
and knock on every single
door of every person
and I would ask them multiple times.
I would twice knock on
doors and ring door bells
in the course of a week to
show them that I'm gonna
relentlessly bother them until they buy
a box of cookies.
Hardcore aggressive in the dirt stuff,
and then I would try to do one kind
of viral move.
I would take a picture of
me holding a sign saying
if you guys help me sell
1,000 boxes of cookies,
I'll do X.
That kind of stuff tends to work.
I would do that on Instagram.
See if I can get a couple celebrities I'd
hit up on Twitter to show
them awareness around this,
and then try to create some
sort of big event that allows
me to really blow it out of the park,
going real up there
while that's trying to get viral,
knocking on doors.
- [Voiceover] Daniel asks, "How
do you decide what to trust
when it comes to news media bias versus
fact reporting?"
- Daniel, this is a
tough question brother.
I mean I don't think I have the answer.
Everybodys got their agenda.
Humans are flawed by nature.
Everybody is gonna put their spin on it.
What I'm really upset about is
watching people
only gravitate to the
people that are like minded.
I take enormous pride in the fact that
I'll watch MSNBC, CNBC, Fox.
I remember for a year there
I was streaming Al Jazeera
not because that I believe
in any one people's
hyperbole, it's just fun to contextualize.
Maybe I'm affected by the fact that I grew
up in a communist country,
and my mom wrote a book
report that the Fidel Castro
was the bravest man in the world.
Because that was the spin that she got
of what he was doing
in Cuba against the US.
If you're self-aware
enough to know that people
are driving their agenda,
and that's just the way it is,
then what you do is you
start hedging everything,
and it creates some level of balance.
I think it's about being open minded
and trying to challenge yourself to see
it from multiple perspectives, but
at some level I think we trust
the people that most talk
about the things we talk about.
I think that at some level
can be slightly dangerous,
especially now in a social
media, digital content,
media at scale world.
There's so many more voices
that can be completely
for us.
I wanna challenge you
VaynerNation to make
sure once a day, once a
week at least once a month
you're reading heavily with an open mind
the counter point to
the things you believe.
- [Voiceover] Homeinstead
Senior care asks,
"Hey Gary, how can a small, local,
non-medial in-home senior care agency
incorporate the Thank You Economy
into our business with our clients
and their families?"
- I think it's a piece of cake actually.
I think you map the data of
the families of the clients
and you follow them on social,
follow them on Facebook and Twitter.
See what they care about,
and if somebody talks about being a huge
Padres fan, maybe you ask their loved
one to take a picture with a Padres hat,
and then you put it in a box, the picture,
physical, yeah, that still happens,
with the Padres hat and you send it
and say how much fun
you're having spending
the time with their loved one.
I'm sure anybody whose got a loved one
in a certain situation, getting
a letter from that place
with this Padres hat,
because you're a Padres fan,
and it's saying how much
you enjoy having their
grandfather or great
grandmother in the facility
would extremely warm their heart,
and create a real depth
moment, and you're doing it
both physically, because then
every time they wear that hat
or see that hat, they
think of that moment.
It's got more longevity.
The Thank You Economy is
quite easy my friends.
The Thank You Economy
is not about the tactics
that I just laid out.
The Thank You Economy
is about the religion
of actually doing it.
- [Voiceover] Florian asks, "How
do you see the world in 2018
once the Apple Watch has
probably become a vital
part in everybody's lives?"
- Florian that's a great question.
I think the Apple Watch has a
significant chance of winning.
I am 100% gonna get it
the day it comes out
to just try it.
I think smart technology is coming
not only to our wrist, but I think it's
coming to our collar.
I actually think in 2018, 2020,
2022 we'll start seeing
the smart shirt at scale
where we can be recording.
I'm looking forward to call Steve.
Hey Stunwin, why is that article not up?
I'm looking forward to that moment.
How is it changed?
Anybody who thinks that the
smartphone which is absolutely
the most important product in the world,
anybody who thinks that
that's where it ends
is clearly not playing
attention to how that whole
world works, and so the smartphone
will be trumped.
Maybe there will always be a device.
Maybe we start putting
it inside of ourselves,
but I do think smart technology coming to
other things in our world,
our sneakers, our hats,
and definitely our collars.
I'm really fascinated.
I invest in a company called Cord.
Link it.
Especially because they're
based around voice,
and I think voice over typing.
I mean look everything
ebbs and flows, right?
There was handwritten, and
then we went hardcore phone,
and now we're back to
handwritten, but it's
thumb written, and I think
we'll go back to voice.
And I think it's gonna look like this.
- [Voiceover] Andy asked,
"I base my Instagram on pics
through my GoPro.
Any tips on differentiating
my content from other
GoPro accounts?"
- Andy, this will have to be a part two,
because I can't give you tips without
knowing what your
objectives and agenda are.
I need a little more color.
Get back on the show.
- [Voiceover] Jared asks,
"Gary, why are scared of cows?"
- Jared, I'm actually not scared of cows.
As a matter of a fact, I grew up
in high school years in
Hunterdon County, New Jersey
and we had two cows.
Big shout out, Maschka.
I'm really not scared of cows.
I was just trying to make
the show entertaining.
- [Voiceover] Ryan asks,
"Some companies' timelines are
nothing but apologies, such as Comcast.
Should they take a break from
Twitter and fix their product?"
- Yes.
And even if your product
is completely broken
you shouldn't be in full apology mode
at all times.
- [Voiceover] John asks,
"Blackberry used to be socially hip.
Could a new social media
approach make a difference
or is it too late?"
- It's too late for Blackberry.
I'm shocked that they're
still in business.
- [Voiceover] Iri asks, "Hey
Gary, my family has always
believed so much in me.
Back in the days were you
more afraid of letting
yourself down or your family?"
- You know, I've always
been really worried
about letting myself down
more so than my parents.
Kinda feel as though
that would be a trickle
down effect if I worried about myself,
then my parents would be proud.
I took at lot of pressure
in my mom's belief in me.
I took enormous pressure
in my dad's belief in me
in the way that he set me up for success
and gave me all that
autonomy at 22 years old
to run a company.
It's always and forever going to be about
me for me.
It's a very selfish thing.
To me, it's I need to make myself
proud, and that's kind of how I navigate
as a human being and
definitely as a business man.
Look I'm not perfect, and nobody is,
and nothing.
The people that know me the best,
they know the only time I'm pissed
and I'm fiesty is when
I'm upset with myself.
- [Voiceover] Kyle asks, "You
get very personal when building
your brand with the public.
How personal is too personal?
Where do you draw the line?"
- Kyle, I think for
everybody it's different.
I draw a line heavily around the kids.
I don't do a lot of stuff
with Xander and Misha,
but I'm also thrilled to put out a picture
of me being on the toilet.
Everybody's got different lines.
Some people are very conservative.
Some people are extremely aggressive.
Some people take photos nude,
some don't even wanna
show their belly button.
Everybody's got their own objectives,
their own agenda, their own
North Star or what's too much.
For me, I just always go on gut feel.
What may be too much
last week might not be
too much tomorrow.
I don't really
I don't really second guess my feelings.
I've done pretty well with them.
For me, it's what I'm
feeling of the moment.
I like getting personal.
I think it allows people
to get closer to you.
I love doing this show for that reason,
and so that's where I'm at.
- [Voiceover] Autumn asks, "I
wondering what everyone thinks
of direct message on Instagram.
Is it an untapped resource?"
- Autumn, the problem with direct message
on Instagram, right, is
that what we're asking
is so far what I've seen
well actually, you know, it's interesting.
Instagram direct message is interesting,
because most people are not following
too many people that they don't wanna be
following on Instagram.
It's very different than
Twitter and other places.
I mean, really if you look at the forum,
I love to look at the
big data of Instagram,
because I have a feeling
that most of the direct
message stuff is a hell of a lot more
scandalous and a hell of a lot more
inappropriate than I think people realize.
Anecdotally what I'm hearing is happening
with Instagram direct
messaging is a hell of a lot
of flirting and a hell of a lot of
I'm trying to look for
the right words here.
Because you're only
following people you wanna
follow, I think from a
marketing standpoint, it's hard
to get into that, because
I look at it like texting.
It's a place where people have no interest
in having people market to them,
and I would stay very away
from Instagram direct messaging
as a marketing tactic,
because I think it's
an inappropriate place to go.
- [Voiceover] A.J. asks, "How
can I engage with an audience
whose interests are private to them?"
- A.J., great name first of all.
Facebook.
Facebook dark posts.
There's a way to use the interest graph to
get to these people who
don't wanna talk about
whatever misgivings or
things they're embarrassed of
or not interested in,
you can go and look at.
You can get into the MasterCard data
and see what they're buying.
There's obviously a lot
of brands in this space.
Actually, hair loss, is that
what we're talking about?
Can somebody pull up Rogaine's
Facebook page right now?
Just for kicks and giggles.
A little real time action.
Just gonna wait,
I'm gonna wait.
A.J.
- [Steve] Pretty small audience.
- Of course, nobody wants to talk about.
Who wants to be like, oh cool.
I'm losing my hair.
I can't wait to be a fan of Rogaine,
but how big is it?
- [Steve] There's no brand page.
There's like a default drug page
that's 870 likes.
- There's no brand page for Rogaine?
- [Steve] I'm gonna
do some more looking.
- You sure.
Nonetheless, as he's going through that,
the 870 people that were okay with going
on the offical page,
there probably is a page,
because I think Steve
will eventually find it,
or there's alternative
brands playing in the space.
The truth is there's a couple ways to
go about it.
I would target men in certain age groups.
There's also female hair loss.
Facebook has enough data
for you to get there
whether you're going
after doctors fan pages
that play in the space,
brands, again, it's absolutely correct
that most people aren't gonna talk about
it on Twitter or follow,
but some are, and that's enough.
What I would say is you
get to the four or five,
15, 17 pages that people are fans of,
you go against that, and
then you create a look a like
audience against that.
You also take the data you have.
I don't know if you're selling direct,
but if you have any email data or anything
of that nature, you can
create lookalike audiences
that's people's behavior
is similar on Facebook,
and that's where you're
getting your scale from.
You got something Staphon?
- [Staphon] 32
- Yeah there we go.
- [Staphon] It had 36,000.
Yeah, so I mean look
there's 36,000 people that are a fan
of the Rogaine page, and
so you're able to actually
go after the people that did that.
I would go after that crew and lookalike
auidences against that, and
I think SEM
this is an example where I think search
probably wins very heavily,
because that's more private action.
I would buy a lot of
keywords on Google, Bing,
Yahoo.
- [Voiceover] Laurie
asks, "If Lizzie opened
up a business as direct
competition to VaynerMedia
or Wine Library, what would you do?"
- Laurie, I would put Lizzie directly
out of fuckin business.
I mean that would be no hesitation.
When it comes to war,
look, I wish A.J. was here.
I think he's in Oklahoma or
in Tennessee on business.
Yeah, I mean, under the context
of the Jets and football
and business, I will slash
anyone's face with a hose.
I don't know what that means,
but if Lizzie is like, if I
came home and Lizzie's like
I'm starting Lizzie Media,
and we're gonna crush it.
I'm like that's great.
I'm gonna put you
directly out of business.
That would be the answer.
- [Voiceover] Mike asks,
"Gary, why do you put so much
emphasis onto sports such as the Jets?"
- I don't know Mike.
Truth is I really don't know.
When I psycho-analyze myself I think
the Jets specifically was
when I was five, six years old
was the first Americana thing.
I often like saying I
learned how to speak English
while watching the Jets.
I mean at some level it
was really Scooby Doo,
and the Great Space
Coaster and Price is Right,
but the Jets were really
kind of that first
American thing that I
associated with the kids
in the neighborhood around.
You get into rhythm.
It's like working out or reading.
My cadence became like I watch the Jets,
and then you go through all
those emotions over 35 years.
You start really building a loyalty to it.
The downs and the downs and the slight ups
and the downs, and so you know, I think
I don't know why I put so much emphasis
around it.
I don't really have the full pledge thing,
but that's my best guess.
- [Voiceover] Ivan asks,
"I am starting a wedding
invitation and stationary boutique
called Spokenforco.
I publish a post on the
company blog every Tuesday.
I spend 10 to 15 hours on each post.
I create visuals to promote
these posts on social media.
However, I realize that I
am getting way more likes
on my hand drawn lettering
posts compared to these
non hand drawn ones.
What should I do?"
- Vivian, you're spending
way too much time on it
in my opinion.
10 to 15 hours feels
completely disproportional
to the value exchange that
you're getting in return.
You need to figure out
how to do it faster.
You also need to become
a little less romantic,
and you need to figure out what your
micro-version of that is, because content
is a gateway drug to opportunity,
and I think your supply
and demand or your value
and return for the time is off kilter.
You're also in a space and
you're a part of this world,
because you love the
design and the creation
and you're an artist at heart,
and so I don't wanna tell you what to do,
but from a business context,
and that's why you asked it on this show
I think there's an inefficiency there,
and you need to figure out how to make
that 10 to 15 hours
closer to one to two max,
45 minutes preferably, so you
can do a hell of a lot more.
Every Tuesday is not enough.
I need more often.
The only way I can get
it more often from you
is if you allow yourself to go faster.
This goes back to an earlier
question in this marathon
of Ts and Is.
I think you're going way too
down the perfection variable.
To prove out my point,
I would ask you to try
to do what you can do.
Do me a favor.
Next Tuesday, spend two hours on it.
See what it does, and
see what the results are.
You may learn from that,
and if you hate what happens,
and there's not a lot of engagement
do it one more time, and
if you can get me to three
strikes where it doesn't work
in three straight Tuesdays
then you can go back to doing your thing,
but my gut tells me
that won't be the case.
- [Voiceover] Lisa asked,
"What's your spirit animal?"
- And Lisa, finally, so everybody
thanks so much for hanging with me.
That was fun.
The marathons fun.
I have a funny feeling we're
gonna have a lot of comments
like this is what you should
do you'll get so many more
answers.
I got so much more value.
Lisa, my spirit animal
is battle cat from Heme.
Actually Ram Man.
Ram Man from He Man.
If you don't know what it look likes,
it looks like this.
Question of the day.
What is your spirit animal?
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
I got nothing yet.
Actually I do have something.
Sorry India.
- [India] That's fine.
- Scared the crap out of you,
and I have a feeling DRock is gonna use
this footage.